[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Anna is
with us in Dallas hi Anna welcome to the
Ramsey
Show hi hi what's
up so I do not need to get a car room
but I want to get one so that I could
build a good credit line and I was just
wondering what you would suggest how old
are you
Anna I just turned 20 okay
why do you think it's important for you
to build a good line of credit what do
you plan to do with that good credit
score I plan I have somewhat of a credit
score just from like I have kept kept up
with like credit cards and such I only
have two and my credit SC is great but I
do plan on buying a house so that I can
rent it maybe a duplex or even building
a duplex since I am in that industry and
I do plan on renting it out to people so
that they can pay pay for the mortgage
what do you what do you do in the real
estate
industry I am an architectural designer
for a customer home builder okay very
cool um so all the talk about the credit
score so the ultimate use for you is
you're wanting to buy a house um we
actually teach a way that you can buy a
house without a credit score which is a
safer way to deal with money in general
because you're not having to enter into
debt in order to do the things that you
want to do you're not having to put the
risk of debt on your life and that
stress in your life in order to do the
things that you want to do so I would
say to you that if you have the money to
buy a car in cash buy the car in cash or
save up until you can the idea of
building up a credit score and when you
really look at what a credit score is
it's simply how you interact with debt
how long you've had debt how much debt
you've had uh what percentage of debt
that you're using that's all that
they're looking at they're not looking
to see if a person can actually
manage the money that they have in their
bank account in their pocket does that
make sense to
you yeah so what would you recommend for
someone like in my instance it's a
smaller bank so it's kind of more
personal is um like what would you
recommend because I know that I do plan
on developing and then building my own
spec homes in the future so I kind of
want a relationship with them if not I
would have to get in touch with some
investors
that I know of let's talk about one
let's talk about one goal at a time
because right now you're like I want to
do I want to do this I want to do that
that that and I love the idea that you
have goals going to towards the future
but the first thought is your first
thought is ultimately how can I get a uh
the house that I want to get that was
your first question and so my thing is
I'm going to teach you how to do it
without a credit score so I would
contact Churchill Mortgage when the time
comes let's get let's get that house and
let's get you living in a house that you
own before we start talking about do a
speck house at 20 years old right first
things first yes sir so I actually plan
to live at home until I'm married just
be more traditional because I do plan on
getting married for young I don't plan
on having any bills really until like I
get the car if I do it on a car
loan so I think that you should pay cash
for the car that's you understand you
don't need a credit SC to buy a house
you understand that you've been lied to
you understand that
it's called manual under underwriting I
did it Dr John delone deloney did it uh
George camell did it we've all done it
so it's not just a theory it's manual
underwriting and all they're doing
you're walking through a lot of the same
processes they're just looking at your
actual money uh how much income you have
coming in as opposed to your debt that's
the only difference that's the only
difference so if I'm you I'm buying my
car in cash simply because I need a car
and then if you have any other debt I'm
clearing it up go ahead while you're
living with your parents save up 3 to 6
months of expenses not for your expenses
at the moment but what you think they
will be once you move out of the house
so you've got that ready moving out of
the house and living in an apartment
will actually help you get the it will
the though and here's the thing because
they're going to they're not going to
count your income like you count it uh
because they're not going to count
people that have zero expenses because
that doesn't exist in the real world and
so you know go ahead and setting up your
life as a young woman independent woman
is not a bad thing um it's not an
immoral thing either by the way um but
it does um it does cost more money and
you'll have your own space your own
place and um yeah I think that's the
direction I would go